next week might as well be called  Nintendo switch week because now the  console is getting a second video  presentation I'm Tony and this is your  upcoming gamespot news update we already  know about the presentation on thursday  but nintendo has announced a treehouse  live stream for friday starting at nine  thirty a.m. eastern time the live event  will take a quote in-depth look at  upcoming games those titles will be  shown off in the presentation the night  before so expect things like zelda  breath of the wild and a few surprise  launch titles there's currently no word  on how long the treehouse live event  will last but before all that kicks off  nintendo will go in-depth on the  switches specs price and launch lineup  the night before that kicks off at 8pm  Pacific 11 p.m. eastern keep an eye on  gamespot for all the new stuff and for  all the latest on nintendo you're  already in the right place